if it is up to the European Union
will soon be the minimum wage in the Netherlands
considerably up the European
parliament has on September 14
agreed to new legislation
about poverty in Europe
to counter
and part of this new legislation
is raising the minimum wage
from now on,
the minimum wage must be 60
are of the median wage
there is 1 whole lot of mathematician and formulas over it
but in practice
it comes down to our minimum wage going to 14
per hour unfortunately
you don't get tomorrow
immediately more money in your bank account
because the Dutch government has time
to transpose this European legislation
according to Dutch legislation
is currently certain
that Dutch legislation
does not comply with the European
standard and that something must be done quickly
Keep the campaign for the latest developments
for hashtag for 14 at
and the website of FNV boy United
to stay on De Hoogte
of all the latest developments